we're kicking off cake week with a man
whose wedding cake i actually ate
because he's married to my business
partner of 25 years
nan and it's the great jimmy fallon ah
thank you very much
you are the best still you're the best
guest that you have at a wedding you're
so much fun
i i cried too hard no i don't even
remember that's more that we had fun the
dancing and everything was just were you
distracted by kermit the frog
look this is unbelievable this is a true
story and
again but we had someone videotaped the
wedding i remember walking down the
aisle
i'm walking down the aisle but i think i
started right because i started
on the and the eye at the end of the
aisle and i looked and i saw everybody
and then
out of nowhere there was a kermit the
frog doll a puppet
in the front row well because you told
the videographer that your wedding song
was going to be rainbow connection
rainbow connection and the moon beam
song by harry nelson
is that that's our that's our those are
wedding songs and so i said yeah
but but i i didn't know that that he
heard me say that or whatever but i just
go like
maybe nancy wanted to come with the frog
and it was like a
life-size kermit it was a giant puppet
and it was sitting there and like a
puppet so it was like you know and it's
just sitting there and i go
that's weird i go well i guess nancy
thought that'd be funny or i don't know
so then nancy comes down the aisle and
i'm not trying not to cry and like how
she looks beautiful and she gets out
there and you look at her and she goes
uh
kermit i go yeah that was used like i
had
no i go who would surprise us at our
wedding everything's perfect
does it send i watched the video no yeah
i watched the video once in every shot
there's he's photobombing
kermit the frog is like these moments
that i thought were intimate like
my you know my dance with my mom you
know and then kermit's head pops out to
die i go
do i go i can't watch this i can't i
didn't know it was the whole time
license that this videographer took from
the husband and wife they're really cool
and nice people but okay so we're gonna
do truth or dare
all right truth or dare here we go this
is all right
uh jerusalem i'll say drew
okay if you have to live on a deserted
island with one former snl cast member
for a year who are you picking
oh no there's so many great people i
love
uh i i would i would say
tina fey oh because we worked together
on update
but also i think that she would uh go
crazy with me on a desert island so she
would figure out some way to get off
the island i would love to be on a
deserted island with tina fey for a year
i
i i am she would get me off that island
uh okay
uh all right so your turn truth or dare
dare
yeah all right see i'm so druth i'm more
jewish
you're truth i'm dara you you can't
handle the truth
you won the gym all right i could have
done a better job nicholson you know
what i love about jack nicholson that he
laughs the way you think he would laugh
he laughs like yeah yeah yeah it's like
air
pumping like yeah it sounds like jack
nicholson laughing it's like
it sounds like a comedy base we went to
laura and i
went to yankee playoff yankee game with
jack nicholson you walked through yankee
stadium and people were just
yelling you can't handle the truth and
every one of you is a legend
every one of his catchers is like just
yeah so i get uh
i get cracker jacks i'm having uh
cracker jackson watching the game
and he goes uh jimmy did you get the
prize yet
you know it sounds like a written line
so i get it i go well no i didn't get
you so i open it up and i go it's a
it's a sticker uh it's a it's a picture
of a snake
he goes you know when i was a kid we
used to get things like
tin whistles now you get a picture of a
snake
[Laughter]
it was just perfect i go what more do
you want from me
time he'd be like you can come over see
i can't do a jack knuckle said
i like hearing you do impressions you
can come over for dinner
you should do a bit where you do
impressions i got to try to guess who
you're doing
if that sounds like i could come over
for dinner i
have no idea who that's harvey fierstein
maybe um
but okay um okay here we go ready uh
dare i'm gonna say uh okay um
that's funny all right uh answer this
question in the deepest voice possible
who do you look up to
[Music]
but i want to do it like jack nicholson
i love them anytime you want to come
over okay i'll i'll do it i'll try a
truth
okay who do you think adam sandler likes
better me or you
oh i'm gonna take a dare yeah
um okay i know the answer to that um
bench press the giant version of five
sleep still christmas
oh my gosh all right here we go
oh my gosh is this going to be
give it to me yeah i'd help you but i
can't
[Laughter]
oh
yes
[Applause]
it's available oh my gosh you are the
best trust me
and guess who reads children's books
adults yeah
and you as an adult are going to love
being in this world
of five more sleeps till christmas
obviously the tonight show needs no
introduction but it does air weeknights
on
nbc at 11 30 10 30 central
you